nous sommes ici au coeur du parc naturel
régional des landes de gascogne un parc
de 200 6000 hectares ce parc a une épine
dorsale c'est la leyre sur laquelle nous
nous trouvons et c'est avec elle que
nous allons partir la découverte des
multiples aspects d'un parc naturel
régional
au détour d'un bras de rivière une
activité plus coloré et plus bruyante
que les autres l'école de canoë sur les
130 km de là l'air c'est le moyen le
mieux adapté pour aller partout et
surtout là où l'on ne va pas à pied
autre détour autre découverte ici l'une
des nombreuses classes vertes qui
viennent chaque année découvrir la
nature après avoir prélevé dans la
rivière où le marais le plus d'espèces
possible de retour au centre du graoux
qu avec leurs enseignants et
l'encadrement du parc les élèves classe
leurs découvertes et les étudie chaque
année ses activités attirent de 100 à
110 mille visiteurs auxquels s'ajoutent
les cent vingt mille visiteurs de
l'écomusée de marquèze et les 75000 du
parc ornithologique du teich le parc
naturel régional il doit d'abord
contribuer au développement de la région
pour le bénéfice de ses habitants en
utilisant les ressources naturelles et
culturelles locales et pour ceux qui
viennent qu'est ce que c'est qu'un parc
qui fonctionne là et bien écoutez un des
gros avantages des perks et qu' ils sont
visibles de très loin il y a une image
de marque des parcs qui peut favoriser
le développement touristique et ils sont
assurés de trouver un parc un
environnement protégé
ce parc est géré par 22 communes la
gironde les landes et la région son
budget 7 millions et demi de francs son
personnel 42 personnes en 90 sa charte
sera révisée et sa surface sans doute
augmenter gage de son succès si l'on
reprend son canoë poursuivre la leyre
jusqu'à son embouchure
on arrive sur le bassin d'arcachon la
visite obligatoire au parc du teich un
parc ornithologique ou livres 300
espèces différentes d'oiseaux c'est ici
que vit la première colonie européenne
des graines plus de 540 des ronds innich
quant aux cigognes le site leur plaît
puisqu'elle y reviennent des affûts sont
aménagés pour que le public observe sans
les effrayer les oiseaux dimanche
l'entrée de ce parc sera gratuite et le
parc dans sa totalité entend bien lui
aussi montré qu propose partout la
nature à l'état pur